hi I'm Evan Carmichael welcome to
another edition of ask Evan in today's
episode I'm going to answer question
from my form administrator GT who posed
a really great question in our forums
and is basically what do you do with
visitors who come dear website but don't
buy it's a huge percentage really the
largest percentage of the types of
people come to your website and what can
you do to increase the conversions and
get them to take more action on your
website so just to illustrate what he's
talking about you know this is a big
circle of all the people who are coming
to our website these are all of our
visitors maybe this will be the number
of people who will buy right away you
know this might be the number of people
who request more information it might
sign up for our newsletter and maybe
this is the number of people who will
share we have social media no they tweet
about it they put out their facebook
page whether you have this huge mass of
other people who aren't doing anything
you might have other types of
conversions maybe somebody clicks on an
advertisement as an example so the idea
is how can we make all of these circles
just a little bit bigger and be able to
convert far more people to to who are
coming to our website convert them to
take action on our website so a couple
of ideas that hopefully can help and I
haven't figured it all out myself this
is a continual challenge that I faced
with my business as well I think anybody
who owns website is always looking for
ways to improve the conversions but the
first thing you can do is segment so
what I would do is look at the different
types of traffic that you're getting so
if you're getting social media traffic
maybe those guys aren't buying a lot
from you so I don't want to focus on the
buy now button maybe I want to focus on
the sharing button somebody comes on
Twitter may not buy from you but they
may tweet about it right they may share
it they may put it on their Twitter or
they may you know Facebook like it and
that stuff you know maybe you don't
think of as a conversion because it
doesn't give you money but what it does
do is it a provides social proof for
what you're selling for your website for
your organization for your product or
service and it will also help you
improve your organic search engine
rankings so somebody is tweeting about
it and that can drive up your s
yo rankings then people who are
searching for your product or service
are going to lend on your website lot
more often so those are guys so you
still want to treat really well and
encourage them to to share even though
they're not going to buy so its segment
so if you do find that social media
traffic doesn't convert well in terms of
mind if somebody comes to your website
from Twitter from facebook then don't
show them the Buy Now button is big show
them the sharing features as bigger so
then they'll want to do that a lot more
and you'll improve your conversion the
left side if you have people who are
coming from referred websites for
example and you find that those guys
really sign up a lot for your newsletter
or people from you know SEO traffic sign
up for your newsletter a lot compared to
tweeting about it then don't make the
social media stuff as prominent make the
newsletter signups more prominent so
what you do is you basically show
different versions of your website to
different people who are coming to find
your site depending where they come from
so the content may be the same you've
written great articles to talk about
what you do and what you sell but all
the surroundings up the next step the
conversion action that you want them to
take can be different depending on where
people come from and you can code that
into your website that it basically
searches when somebody comes from your
site it says where they come from and
you just show a different conversion
next step for them depending on where
they've come from so that can really
help boost your your conversions the
next thing that I would think about here
is simplify your site design and as
website owners will usually start with a
nice clean website and we've got our
content and we've got our headline and
then we start out in a whole bunch of
other stuff right we add our little
buttons in and we add more eyes and we
add conversion steps newsletter by now
tons of products you know we these stop
convergence we put them in our content
here and soon it becomes as ginormous
mess and people don't know where to go
and if you look at you know when you
have too many options for what to do
next we usually give up and go back and
find something else so what you want to
do is make it simple again so identify
the top one or two conversion steps that
you want people to take and highlight
those and illuminate everything else and
we just went through a new site design
as well and it tends to kind of creep up
some there's a new toolbar that comes
out you want to put it on your website
it's the greatest thing since sliced
bread so you got to have it on your site
but it adds confusion and people will
often leave your website instead of
converting for any of them so what you
want to do is again take away all the
stuff that isn't super important right
so we have our headline we have our
content and you have maybe you know an
action item here and an action item here
or whatever your site design is and it's
a lot simpler a lot easy for people to
do and they're more likely to convert to
those steps so again you're identifying
the primary stuff you want them to take
maybe a secondary and that's all you
wanting besides your content and again
these can change depending on where
people are coming from so it might be
really big you know share social media
at the coming from Twitter or might be
really big sign up for our newsletter if
they're coming from search engine
traffic and again you have to test to
see you know what type of traffic
inverts at different levels the next
thing that can help across the board is
emotion so what you want to do is tell
stories that have an emotional
connection to make people want to take
that next step right if you look at most
websites it's pretty boring right there
you know maybe the corporate bio or
entrepreneurs going to hiding behind the
website people like to buy from people
and they like to convert with people
they like to take the next step by
working with a person so what you want
to try to do is tell your personal story
and tell your customer stories and do
that before you start selling right if
you want them to sign up for your
newsletter you don't say sign up for my
newsletter you talked about the people
who sign up for your newsletter and have
gotten great value from it so you give
them an emotional connection to want to
take that next step with you and that
will increase across the board for any
type of traffic and any type of
conversion step make sure you're getting
that emotion across the last thing I
would do
is date so if you think about when you
are in love and your find their
relationship you date before you get
married right and it's the same thing
when you're dealing with a web visitor
potential customer somebody can
potentially convert for you you want to
go in and ask for the sale right away
you want to get to know them and you
want to date first build a relationship
and then it's more likely that you're
going to be able to convert them so if
you're looking at just purely from web
visitors to bind on the site versus
newsletter subscribers to bind on the
site people are more likely to buy from
you if they're on your newsletter and
they know you they like you they trust
you they want to do business with you so
you want to give it easy next steps to
be able to get people to convert with
you so I would definitely start by
looking at my newsletter get people to
sign up for that make it super easy just
ask their name and email address and
start dialoguing with them and your have
a much greater chance to be able to
convert them to buy your products and
just saying hey by now kind of take it
or leave it approach we will also follow
our customers on Twitter try to engage
with them we look for opportunities to
send them brownies example one of our
customers tweeted that her recognition
was broken in her office and she was
working at the starbucks so we sent her
brownies and said we hope it feels
better you know soon in the air
condition is fixed it's a hot summer day
at the time so that those kinds of
stories win over customers and it could
be you know borderline customers who
become customers for life or prospect
customers who see how great a person you
are and they get tied to your story and
then they want to continue to you know
sign up with you and do more a lot more
business with you so look at trying to
date with your customers before you try
to seal the deal a little bit too early
and you'll improve your conversion rates
a lot so I hope that helps I'd love to
hear what you guys are doing I know I
don't have all the answers and these are
only a couple things that you can do to
improve your conversions so you know
please give the video a thumbs up if you
liked it below and it also love to hear
what you guys are doing if you wanna
live a comment under the video and stay
tuned for next episode
you
you
you